لا نخطئ هناك أ
خطر اليوم من هناك ونحن
ينبغي أن يقال بين الأصدقاء
أخبرك بما حدث مؤخرًا
الشهر هو التحدي بالنسبة لنا لأننا
يبدأ في التحول في الموضوعات
الطاقة وتكلفة الحرب
ليس هو نفسه في أوروبا
الولايات المتحدة
[موسيقى]
وفوق كل الخيارات التي قمت بها
أهداف حصة
على وجه الخصوص سهم
أعمال التخفيض أو أعمال الرقائق
خيارات من شأنها أن تفكك الغرب
لأنها تخلق مثل هذه الاختلافات
بين الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية و
أوروبا فقط لكل هؤلاء
الذين يعملون في كثير
شركات
علينا فقط أن نقول لأنفسنا أننا نقوم بالمزيد
استثمار
الجانب الأخر لى
التقارب بين الولايات المتحدة
من امريكا
وفرنسا والأوروبيون الآخرون
ينير في هذا الصدد وهو حقيقي
منذ اليوم الأول للنزاع
من المهم للغاية